bon bah ils sont toujours pas revenus en
fait donc je vous ai trouvé un autre
épisode des corses de recherche toujours
dans la série y voir l'invisible et ben
je vous laisse regarder
et puis bonnes vacances à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toutes nos salutations gère spectatrices
et spectateurs
vous ne venez pas de voir le motif de la
prochaine robe pierre cardin vous savez
ce jeune créateur au bug non ceci est le
résultat d'une observation réalisée à
l'aide d'un microscope
mais pas n'importe lequel c'est les bons
l'avènement de microscopes mais trafic
[Musique]
les scientifiques du laboratoire de
magnétisme et physique du solide ici
même à meudon bellevue ont développé un
nouveau dispositif d'observation
dynamique et voici le type de films
qu'ils obtiennent
on
hypnotisant ans n'est ce pas ce n'est
pas sans rappeler les effets surprenants
des paradis artificiels décrit par
charles baudelaire mais en réalité ces
images poétiques nous donne à voir les
changements qui ont lieu à l'intérieur
d'un geste a soumis un champ magnétique
attention ce que j'entends ici par
crystal n'est pas celui des flûtes de
champagne que la maîtresse de maison et
peut-être un jour le maître de maison
rangé au fond du vaisselier non il
s'agit ici d'un cristal métallique en
effet à température ambiante
la plupart des métaux comme le fer forme
des cristaux c'est à dire des solides
dont les atomes sont agencées de façon
régulière avec d'autres cocasses les
verres en cristal ne sont justement pas
constitué de cristaux les recherches
réalisées par les scientifiques de
meudon bel ont pour but d'observer les
phénomènes microscopique menon
alimentation dans medal l'observation
est réalisée sur des fils de fer de
nickel de cobaye ou d'un oxyde de fer
est de plomb l'échantillon est
préalablement préparé sur sa surface
parfaitement poli
les chercheurs dépose dans liquide dans
lequel baignent de très fines particules
magnétiques
c'est ce que l'on appelle en faire au
fluide une fois l'échantillon
positionner dans le microscope une
bobine est placée autour pour générer un
champ magnétique variable cela
reviendrait à approcher de l'échantillon
à leyment plus ou moins forts orientés
dans un sens puis dans l'autre
que se passe-t-il à ce stade
l'échantillon de cristal métallique est
constituée de petits éléments de volume
invisibles à l'oeil nu
ap les domaines magnétique c'est
l'évolution de ces domaines en présence
d'un champ magnétique que les
scientifiques étudient autrement dit
comment les échantillons cément pile
incroyable en surface du cristal
certains de ces petits domaines vont
attirer les fines particules du ferro
celui dans lequel baignent l'échantillon
ses fines particules les tons noir elle
décide alors des motifs sinueux dans
l'objectif du microscope les motifs qui
se dessine dans les fers en fluides
révèle donc les modifications internes
du cristal soumis aux champs magnétiques
aussi clairement que si l'on sent poudre
l homme invisible de farine
cette étude permet donc aux
scientifiques de mieux comprendre le
processus d'aimantation et contribuer à
une meilleure connaissance de ces
matériaux de plus en plus utilisés dans
notre monde moderne
et en cette veille des jeux olympiques
de tokyo nous pouvons désormais réveillé
de voyager jusqu'au japon dans les
transports à sustentation magnétique et
pourquoi pas imaginer de planer sur une
planche à roulettes en lévitation
ainsi le microscope métallos graphique
nous a rendus visibles les effets
surprenants de l'électromagnétisme une
science bigrement attirante
[Musique]
abonnez vous nom de zeus